Speaker 1: All right. I don't want to
spend a ton of time on this just because
she she's such a despicable person
and obviously a liar that it's like,
how much time do I need to spend reminding you
that Congresswoman Lauren Boebert is a liar? But
this is actually sort of an important story.
There was this debt ceiling vote, of course,
and Lauren Boebert is now claiming that the fact
that she didn't vote one way or the other on the
bill was a sort of protest because they weren't
letting her do her job. And it's this big moral
stand that she's taking. Except now video has been
released of Lauren Boebert trying to sprint into
the Capitol to vote. She was just late. She just
missed the vote. That's all that happened. So let
me give you the comings and goings of this. Here
is Lauren Boebert back in Colorado explaining that
she is protesting against the debt ceiling bill.
She's against adding debt. She tweeted, quote,
Call it a protest. There is no there's absolutely
no way to ever justify adding another 4 to $6
trillion in debt. This is more D.C. self-created
garbage that I will always fight against. And
here's the video that she put out about this.
Speaker 3: Hey, everyone, I am back in Colorado.
But let's talk about D.C.. No excuses. I was
ticked off. They wouldn't let me do my job, so
I didn't take the vote. Once again, Washington's
power machine shoved a multitrillion dollar bill
down our throats, refused to allow debate or
amendments, disregarded everything we fought
for in January to actually allow representatives
to do their jobs. And instead they served us up
a crap sandwich. Call it a no show protest. But I
certainly let every one of my colleagues and the
country know I was against this garbage of a bill.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's a no show protest,
except here is video taken by CNN
associate producer Morgan Rimmer
of Boebert trying to sprint in and
realizing being told the votes over.
You missed it. Does this look like
someone who's not trying to vote?
Speaker 3: Just close it. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Yes,
there is Lauren Boebert sprinting
up the steps of the Capitol
to try to vote. This is a lie. She is a liar.
It's political theater, but it is very low end
political theater. Lauren Boebert has nothing
interesting to add about the debt ceiling. She
has no relevant insight. She has no particular
experience that makes her someone to listen to
on this issue. She isn't even important enough
for anyone to bother paying attention to whether
she is or isn't voting. And she's turned all of
it into a big story about herself. But it was
all the lie. She just was late to vote and then
retroactively came up with this stupid story.
The only other thing I'll say is she won
by only 500 votes. She can be defeated.
She has an opponent, Adam Frisch, and
it would be great to defeat her in 2024.